I continue to in bewildered fashion wait
for someone who is running against
Donald Trump in the 2024 nomination or
might soon be running against Trump to
Levy some kind of criticism of Donald
Trump some kind of policy critique draws
some distinction between what they would
do and what Donald Trump would do we
have a couple of examples here and the
one that is getting weirder and weirder
by the day is former South Carolina
governor and former ambassador to the
United Nations under Donald Trump Nikki
Haley Nikki Haley has announced that she
is running against Trump right okay good
so like what would you do differently
well nothing but I'm younger and I'm a
woman and I'm a minority identity
politics has been Nikki Haley's approach
so far it has now been weeks and Nikki
Haley went on Fox News and she was asked
are you going to draw any distinction
with Donald Trump and her latest thing
is well let's see if he criticizes me
first that you're not going to kick
sideways but we've seen Donald Trump on
the debate stage and I guarantee you he
will kick sideways and he will come
after you yeah
um and so and you're gonna have to stand
up to that kick back when I'm kicked I
kick back and what will your argument
against him
well let's wait and see if he's got a
criticism first he hasn't done anything
he hasn't said anything so I know
everybody wants that's very much untrue
talk about Trump but Martha truly and we
had a couple of thousand people in South
Carolina we had packed rooms in New
Hampshire not one person asked me about
Donald Trump not one and now we're in
Iowa people really want to talk about
the issues and I think that's a lot of
it they're done with the status quo
they're done with talking about all the
old school things they want to talk
about how we're going to go forward and
I think what we need to make sure we
tell American families is we're going to
stop this socialism creep that we're
seeing we're going to stop this any
criticisms of trump socialism is bad
fetism that's happened around our
country we're going to make people stand
for America again and be proud of
America yeah so remember she says as
soon as Trump criticizes me I will
criticize him Trump brutally criticized
her last week remember he he said she
was such a terrible Governor that he
made her Ambassador as a favor to the
people of South Carolina to get her out
of the state he posted quote on a truth
through social Trump posted last week
the greatest thing Nikki Haley did for
our country in the great state of South
Carolina was accepting the position of
U.N Ambassador so that the incredible
then Lieutenant Governor Henry McMaster
could be governor of South Carolina
where he has done an absolutely
fantastic job that was a big reason why
I appointed Nikki to the position it was
a favor to the people I love in South
Carolina she's basically saying I have
criticisms of trump but I'm going to
wait till he criticizes me hard to find
a more serious criticism than that and
then in addition to this Trump just a
few days ago saying there are people out
there with no polling support basically
auditioning for vice president when
Trump said the following nobody else was
running it was only Nikki Haley that
this could be applied to a lot of people
are right now auditioning you know that
a lot of people a lot of people that are
running at one percent two percent three
percent no percent
we have a couple that are joining
they're at no percent
I say I wonder what they're doing I
think they're auctioning right now for
they're auditioning right now for vice
president in a sense they are kind of
auctioning themselves off Trump's
Freudian slipped there did Trump slipped
there may be more Freudian than we might
think uh but this was something we
suggested I kind of agree with Trump I
do think there is an element of let me
run to get attention but not criticize
Trump draw no distinctions whatsoever
from Trump on policy and see if maybe
that can get me the vice presidentship
so that's Nikki Haley still unwilling
unable whatever to draw any distinctions
other than identity distinctions between
her and the guy she is running against
let's next talk about another guy who
might be entering the race Tim Scott
Nikki Haley fine she's not going to tell
you anything she disagrees with Trump on
she's not going to draw any policy
distinction she's only going to talk
about identity fine
what about Tim Scott Tim Scott is a
Republican senator from South Carolina
Tim Scott was also given the opportunity
by Sean Hannity to draw a distinction
between himself and Trump when it comes
to policy Tim Scott has not yet
announced that he's running but the
rumors are that he may well be doing
that
he didn't do it either take a look at
this what are the differences in terms
of
policy positions that's for example you
may have with President Trump
probably not very many at all I'm so
thankful that we have President Trump in
office frankly the policies that we were
able to pass from 2017 to 2020 were
Monumental and thankful any criticisms
of the guy you might run against since
you'll have to justify why someone would
vote for you over Trump no his policies
were great really I mean it's very
beautiful beautiful presidency Hannity
asked Tim Scott a second time
any just anything you want to mention
here Tim Might we then find ourselves in
a position where you know maybe we'll
have six seven eight maybe ten maybe 20
Republican candidates on a stage that
mostly agree on what the governing
philosophy and ideology should be for
the country what works in the country
that's what we're going to have then
where are the differences what would the
differences be do you think
that's a great question Sean I would
simply say this what I'm learning on my
faith in America Tour is yes in order to
decide whether to run for president I
guess he's learning during a faith in
America Tour oh my goodness tell my
story as an African-American who's born
into poverty
he's doing the identity politics thing
too oh my God these people they no
identity Politics the two people who are
or might be running against Trump talk
only about their identity when asked
about policy differences then a single
parent household the strength of my
community my Chick-fil-A Mentor who
happened to be a white guy a citadel
graduate from in South Carolina he
taught me that you no matter where
you're born you can rise beyond your
circumstances if you're willing to
perspire because you're inspired by the
American story leaning into that helped
change my life bringing people together
black folks and white folks not because
of the color of our skin but because we
have one single Focus we believe you
might be noticing there are no policy
distinctions here the goodness of
America I want to share with people why
we should be proud of who we are and at
the same time debunk the lies all right
we're gonna stop
this is looking like the identity
politics primary of 2024. on the
Republican side let's imagine Tim Scott
gets in next okay we will have Trump
Nikki Haley and Tim Scott any policy
differences at all that any of you want
to cite anything that Trump did during
his presidency that was bad that you
would have done differently
no I don't know but if you want a
younger minority woman you can go with
Nikki Haley it's Trump's policies with a
younger minority woman there's Haley if
you want the slightly older than Nikki
Haley but still younger than Trump and
black version of trump
then you've got Tim Scott that you can
vote for this is unbelievable and it is
another one of these examples of how the
Wright loves to claim the left is all
about canceling and suppressing Free
Speech actually it seems like it's the
right that that is oh the left is all
about
um you know regulating businesses and
telling them what they can do oh it's
actually the right who wants to tell
Twitter and all these other companies
what to do we I could go down the very
very long long list the the left is
about restricting people's freedoms and
it's the right that wants to determine
what people can do in bedrooms for
example and in this case it's the right
that loves to say the left is constantly
doing identity politics identity
politics identity politics they have two
and soon will have three candidates who
seem only willing to challenge the
former president's
um a candidacy on the basis of identity
on the basis of identity Tim Scott being
asked give us some policy differences it
sound like a going to have a bunch of
people on stage who all agree uh well
listen you know as I go around the
country as a black man what this is now
what the Republican party has become
identity politics it is madness but you
know what
if their voters don't care about policy
maybe this is the smart thing just have
them pick based on identity do you want
the uh Indian American female version of
trump or do you want the black American
male version of trump what what is it
you want because on policy they're not
talking about it and voters quite
frankly don't seem to care wild and
wacky times I'll have these clips for
you on my YouTube channel find it at
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
make sure you're subscribed folks we're
trying to push towards 2 million
subscribers and also be aware of the
David Pacman show now available in
Spanish for our Spanish speakers
davidpackman.com Spanish
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David pakman show continues to be a
community and audience supported program
we do what we do thanks to the support
of viewers and listeners like you
primarily toward through something
called the membership program you can
sign up at joinpakman.com one of the
ugly secrets of the world that we live
in is that when you support Independent
Media through a lot of platforms they're
taking 10 sometimes even 30 or 40
percent of every dollar that you
contribute with the membership program
we pay 2.9 percent to swipe those credit
and debit cards and keep the rest so
it's the really most efficient way to
support the work we do you can sign up
at joinpakman.com you get of course
access to the bonus show and so many
other great benefits
joinpakman.com is the place to be let's
hear from the most important people it
is that community that I mentioned that
are the most important folks in the
audience we like to hear from you
regularly via Discord you can find our
Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord and we are going to start today
with Evan from San Francisco Evan
welcome to the program I uh am anxiously
awaiting uh hearing about what's on your
mind today my friend
thank you
Evan you're on the air it's your turn to
speak now can you hear me yes
no yep I can hear you fine
all right Evan's starting us off with
some beautiful technical problems which
you love to see let's instead go to
Bishop from Kentucky Bishop from
Kentucky welcome to the program uh once
you unmute yourself we'll be able to
talk and uh I'm glad to uh hear about
what's on your mind today
oh hello yeah you're on the air
okay
um I just wanted to talk about you've
seen um the recent improvements of um AI
like deepaks and stuff right yes
do you think this is ever going to be
like a problem when it comes to like
legal cases like people could um conjure
up evidence that doesn't actually exist
and like without realistic they sound
like and how fast it's improving it
seems to be a bit worrying and I wonder
what your opinion is on that yeah well
so one of the things that we've seen
when it comes to this exact sort of uh
problem is whenever some new technology
becomes widespread which allows either
plagiarism of a new kind or um
fabrication of a new kind
you then create essentially a whole new
like industry of tools and experts
designed to authenticate or to determine
is something plagiarism or is a piece of
evidence real or fake so my expectation
would be that if indeed
using these tools to create fake
evidence in Trials becomes an issue
there will be a new cottage industry of
experts and tools developed
to attempt to authenticate whether
evidence that is presented is really
authentic now is it possible that the AI
technology gets very far ahead of the
authentication technology and it's
impossible to authenticate stuff maybe
but usually whenever this happens
Technologies and experts are developed
and trained to then authenticate what
that new technology is making possible
mm-hmm
yeah that sounds fair I was uh I've just
like seen mostly jokes like um Deepak
jokes like recently like with like Trump
or Biden or Andrew Tate and they're
pretty funny but it's like it was like
slightly worrying how um realistic they
were yeah
um the amount of time that it's like
taken to like Reach This level of
uncompetency when it comes to AI is like
quite astounding I didn't really think
we'd see anything like it at least like
in my early lifetime but it's happening
a lot quicker than I thought and I just
wanted to know your opinion on it it is
happening very quickly you know so far
the Deep fakes of me that have been sent
to me aren't very convincing but
I'm guessing at some point in the next
year or two someone's going to send me a
deep fake of me and it'll probably be
shockingly realistic and it sounds very
scary to be honest
I'm sure that will happen yeah all right
Bishop thank you for the call I
appreciate it
thank you so much all right there is
Bishop from Kentucky why don't we go
next to Jacob from Denver Jacob from
Denver welcome to the David packman show
what's on your mind today uh
you're on the air
cool I just have a question about
um hypocrisy so I've been following your
channel now for a long time and it's
it's all over the Internet it's all over
news this idea that you know someone's
being hypocritical is like is it even
valuable to point out hypocrisy anymore
well politics or in general or is it
just is it a fallacy it's not a fallacy
no it's it's not a fallacy to point out
hypocrisy it helps us to get at sort of
the root of what elected officials
really care about right like for example
if an official claims to care about the
deficit when a Democrat is president but
not when a republican is President it
suggests to us they don't really care
about the deficit they care about
scoring political points and then it
allows us to maybe more accurately
assess and evaluate the things that they
say so in that sense it's not fallacious
you are getting at a reality though
which is not only have Republican
elected officials clearly stopped trying
to avoid the appearance of hypocrisy and
double standards their voters also don't
seem to care so there is a question
about the utility of us pointing out
right-wing hypocrisy when the elected
officials don't care and their voters
don't seem to care is it just a waste of
time I think that that's a perfectly
fair question to ask
yeah I agree I I do I do feel that it's
there should be some sort of value
behind it yeah but it's almost like a
fatigue at this point it's like how much
longer can anybody stand watching
anybody call somebody else a hypocrite
it just it feels so vapid at this point
a hundred percent it does it shouldn't
but it does because consistency has been
abandoned even as a goal and that's
really the sad part
yeah all right man thanks for the call
all right yep uh Jacob from Denver great
to hear from you let's go next to David
from St Petersburg now is this St
Petersburg Florida or St Petersburg
Russia
oh boy David from St Petersburg
welcome to the program
and last chance for David from Saint
Petersburg sadly we will never know was
it Russia
or was it Florida very sad very very sad
let's go next to Jack from Connecticut
Jack from Connecticut welcome to the
program
good morning David can you hear me I can
hear you fine
wonderful it's nice to be back I like to
bring up a personal topic today okay
personal to you or to me
uh personal to me but it kind of kind of
relates to everyone in this audience
sort of sure
um so about a couple of weeks ago uh
President Biden announced that the
federal government will be ending the
covert emergency yep on the federal
scale and that hits personal to me for
two reasons yes uh number one it's
unreal it's out the date is May 11th
which is also my birthday okay and
number and number two it's also the day
before the three-year anniversary of my
grandmother passing from this deadly and
very real disease
okay um
so I just wanted to ask you a question
about this sure um do you think this is
a real light at the end of the tunnel in
terms of the end of the code emergency
or do you see this as Biden's way of
easing into the gop's demands given the
high stakes negotiations regarding
budget and the deficit ceiling listen so
there's there's sort of two parts to
this the first part is does Biden ending
the covet emergency
change anything about the reality of
what's happening with covid out in the
world the answer is of course not it's a
political determination it's a political
change we haven't we have an emergency
we don't have if I if right now I do I
was president and I declared Ebola an
emergency it wouldn't change anything
about ebola it would just be a political
designation
so the first thing is this isn't really
meaningful in terms of covid now in
terms of do I think that the the covet
is over no covet's not over when you
look at Global cases and deaths they are
down quite a bit and they continue to
decline
and there's the question of whether we
say is this now
part of the background level of risk
sort of like you could go out and get
the flu and you're aware of it you could
go out and get coveted and you're aware
of it but we now say we are not
considering covid something special
we're saying covet's still there but
we're sort of including it in the total
risk of going out and you might get a
stomach bug or the flu or get hit by a
car whatever the case may be I I don't
know when the right time is
I don't think that what Biden is doing
is really being pushed or that he's
being kind of pressured by Republicans
necessarily I mean very few people are
talking about the Federal Emergency
designation anyway
uh and most people aren't acting like
anything is going on anyway so I I think
that it's really more of a political
decision and maybe even a financial
decision but I think really to figure
out what's going on you need to be
looking at data that is totally separate
from anything Joe Biden says
yeah it's very unfortunate that this
whole Fiasco has turned into a political
situation especially coming from someone
who lost a beloved family member from
this terrible disease but uh fortunately
at the top not fortunately I'm sorry uh
at the time there wasn't adequate
testing available right so there was no
way to point out anything in a sense but
it's very fortunate to know that um
things have improved in some way and um
there's some way we can see some light
at the end of the tunnel if that makes
sense yeah yeah no question about it and
um a lot of the light at the end of the
tunnel depends on personal risk
tolerance and a lot of things that are
different for everybody so I appreciate
the call Jack and be well okay thank you
very much David I appreciate it all
right there is Jack from Connecticut
bringing up a number of important issues
let's go next to oh I don't know how
about Jose in New York Jose welcome to
the program
hello
um David it's by the way it's um it's
Portuguese but I'm very impressed you
got the last name correct I didn't even
say the last name
uh no I'm sorry last time uh when I was
uh twittering but anyway okay so my
question is to you is um
when the like
back in like the 1800s and during the
turn of the labor unions yeah and such
like that when people started revolting
and getting violent because their
situations were poor yes do you think
that's something that may be happening
in the future as if like uh like during
j6 people were clearly angry
but their anger was directed towards
something else like do you think we are
due for violence I'm not sure I
understand what you're saying you're
saying is it possible that in the future
violence will happen like on j6 but
directed at something different I I
apologize if I'm not understanding I'm
like to the government like the left
side the right side because people's
situations are so
um
it's so like diminished from like back
when my parents were were like starting
up and that kind of stuff what's what's
diminished
like the um wages the cost of living uh
opportunity for like housing
like
okay so you I I I am just not
understanding what you mean so get be so
you're saying housing cost is up wages
are flat so people are upset will that
lead to violence you're saying
um in a sense yes like if um
I'm sorry I was I was still formulating
this question
um
um when uh when people like uh I'm sorry
you can skip over me I'm sorry all right
I I appreciate the call it sounds like
there's an interesting question in there
let's uh call back call back when we
figured out what it is and I would I
would love to answer it let's go next to
Stoney from Indiana Stoney from Indiana
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
hey David uh how are you I'm doing well
good um yeah so I was just wondering I
know that you kind of side on the side
of the capitalists and some of the
viewers or more on the leftist side but
I wanted to see your take on crypto
specifically and uh kind of there's been
some legislation from Elizabeth Warren
and things of that nature
um just wanted to see if you're a crypto
bro or kind of where you stand on that
whole side of things yeah so I've got a
couple dozen videos about crypto I
bought Bitcoin and ethereum back in I
believe it was 2016 and
um I've been clear that I have no
emotional attachment to crypto I don't
think crypto is uh going to save the
world I also don't think crypto is
uniquely evil I basically took the
approach back in 2016 this might be a
thing I want to put about three percent
of my assets into it
um crypto Bitcoin and ethereum did
really really well so that three percent
would become six percent and then I
would sell half and then it would become
six percent canonide cell half and
obviously more recently crypto has
diminished in value and I have
absolutely no prediction about where
it's going Bitcoin could be in five
years at a million dollars or it could
be at zero I have no idea I think it's
very volatile I think it's risky and I
think
um many of the use cases that are cited
aren't really that interesting or
compelling
so I I guess more so to my point it's
behind the I I've never been much of a
crypto person I worked in Finance on uh
in Wall Street and that sort of thing so
um I we kind of stayed away from it
because it seemed like you know a fairy
tale but the more I look into it the
technology seems very fascinating
um the blockchain sort of Technology
seems fascinating in of itself even you
look at the things like George Santos
getting in trouble for the election or
campaign funds that sort of stuff if it
was available on the blockchain that
sort of transparency I think would help
with politicians and knowing what
they're doing with their funds and just
making everything publicly available
through that record so I don't know if
you have anything else to add on that
but that was just kind of my two cents
no I mean listen you you're not wrong I
just don't know that it's that obvious
that the blockchain is the only solution
to like having not not fallen for the
lives of George Santos I just I I'm I'm
not as technologically savvy as one
would need to be for me to definitively
say the blockchain is the solution to
George Santos's lies or there's five
other solutions that are just as well I
don't know
I don't think we prevent like towards
Santas because clearly there's not like
the proper vetting going on from the the
sort of committees but more so my point
is uh if if all of these transactions
from every politician was available on
the blockchain
um such as how crypto is designed the
same thing with the fraud if there's
fraud in crypto you can trace it all the
way back to its Origins yeah uh because
of the transparency so more so just like
from a corrupt politician perspective
even in Indiana our secretary of state
bought a bunch of stuff was kind of put
his feet to the fire about it and we
still elected him because it's a
Republican state we don't really care so
it's just those sort of things that I
mean from a transparency perspective we
have zero you know trust in our
government when it comes to what they're
using the funds for I think from a
technological perspective it's very
um interesting and
um you know just more ways for us to
trust the government and of itself I
mean you this thing could be applicable
all the way to the police forces being
forced to yeah you know Stoney I don't I
think I get it I I just I don't know
that blockchain is what we need for
police accountability vote counting
determining I think that we're starting
to go into like it seems like it can't
it doesn't make sense to me that it's
the solution to everything and that's
where it starts to get a little bit
weird for me but listen um I appreciate
the call and we're going to continue to
follow it all right thanks David all
right Stoney from Indiana we're going to
take the quickest of breaks and then
we'll be right back and hear from more
of you
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's go
back to Discord and hear from a few more
people first and foremost I want to go
to Adrian from Wyoming one I I don't
know why Wyoming is so interesting to me
I've never been in a such a small
population I would like to visit Adrian
and see what it's all about you know
hi David pleasure pleasure to speak with
you can you hear me yes I can
perfect
um yeah I live in Laramie Laramie um so
my parents actually grew up in New York
but my
both teach at the University of Wyoming
um uh it's the only four-year school in
the state so it's kind of an anomaly
when it comes to like all the other
small rural towns but it's beautiful you
should actually definitely go drive
through the mountains and see it all but
that's not um the focus of my question I
was actually wondering a little bit
about a different part of the world sure
in that
um I know so you uh were born in
Argentina and I was wondering there's an
emerging group Within
um the South American left like leaders
like Petro
um
Castillo until he was ousted
um uh amlo I can't remember
I don't know if Castro is part of it
um in Central America but I was
wondering if you were thinking
um what your thoughts are on this new
rise of leftist leaders like Lula and if
it's built to last or if it's
potentially
um susceptible to more right-wing
takeovers like we just saw in Peru and
what the left in South America would
need to do to ensure that it's got more
staying power as it's a relatively new
phenomenon listen I don't know if it has
staying power I know that on this issue
there's some people in the audience who
like to say oh I'm some right winger and
my family was part of the Argentinian
right wing and that's how we were able
to get out and we were supporters of the
dictatorship in our you know none of
that stuff is true uh all of my family
has been on the left and many are even
further left than I am and uh you know I
have no
um sort of like familial opposition to
left Wingers in Latin America the
concern I've had with some of the Latin
American so-called left-wing leaders of
the last 20 years is that often it's the
exact same sort of Playbook it's the
populist rhetoric and they do some good
things for the poor but they rape and
pillage many of the resources of the
countries in some cases they abscond
with obscene amounts of Cash There's not
always freedom of the press there's not
always freedom of the courts we've seen
in Venezuela and elsewhere so I don't
take any kind of like big picture this
is good or this is bad I'm on the left
right so like as I've said before
between bolsonaro and Lula if those are
my choices I'm picking Lula I also have
concerns about Lula and I outlined them
in the video I did about him and I I
have to say it a thousand times I still
choose him over Bolson sorrow but I
don't think Lula is God's gift to
Progressive politics either you know so
I think we just have to wait and see and
evaluate these individually
absolutely I just I I hope that they're
like I hope that
um
was I gonna say I was just in Colombia
and I was speaking with a lot of like my
younger friends there who say they
um they have hope but they're um
and they're but they're a little worried
uh because the The Divide here is
relatively Stark like as in the um in
the US between like younger and older
Generations as to the image of the ideal
Society going forward
um so yeah I was just curious about your
take and I appreciate the call thank you
very much for your time all right thank
you Adrian from Wyoming great to hear
from you very much appreciate it why
don't we go next to uh Tommy from
Wisconsin Tommy from Wisconsin welcome
to the program what's on your mind today
hi David can you hear me all right yes I
can
okay um I guess I just really had a
comment about Nikki Haley and you know
the possibility and I know it's a ways
off that she might end up as Trump's VP
sure all right do you think
if he chooses her will she will he will
Trump use her
name Nikki Haley or use her Indian name
what do you think what do you think
Tommy
which name do you think he'll use
um I suspect he'll probably just refer
to her as Nikki Haley so he doesn't end
up slaughtering her like suchintendo Cur
or so here's the thing this is the thing
so for people who don't know Nikki
Haley's given name was actually nimirata
rondawa okay so um her name now now she
goes by Nikki Haley there's two sides to
this first Trump would love to give her
the Barack Hussein Obama treatment
which would be to refer to her as
nimerata rondawa the problem though is
Trump really struggles with names as we
know you know suchintendalker and Virat
Kohli and when he went to India and
tried to pronounce the names of cricket
players it went really badly so that
would be a reason for Trump to stay away
from that but I think Trump would love
to use her birth name as a way to subtly
criticize her uh with the kind of
xenophobia that he's known for
makes sense to me yeah we'll see what
happens though
right absolutely all right Tommy thank
you beautiful thank you for taking my
call great to hear from you appreciate
it why don't we go next to Nick from
Harlem Nick welcome to the program what
can I do for you today
hey there can you hear me okay yes I can
okay the first time long time thank you
so much for your work um I actually have
a question about uh the Pac-Man Finance
Channel sure
uh so I know you have a background in uh
like you have educational background in
finance and I don't know if you've ever
taught or if you teach courses but for
me the Pac-Man Financial has been like
an educational experience as I'm sure is
one of your intentions yes I've even had
the opportunity to like share it with
um some of my like conservative
conservative
um I guess I would say acquaintances and
you know they end up also tuning into
other you know the other Pac-Man Channel
your main Channel and that you know it's
kind of I found that kind of be to be
interesting and my question is I guess
um would you ever consider doing a
call-in aspect for Pac-Man Finance like
not necessarily a financial advice
um but just you know how to or you know
if folks kind of have you know specific
questions about their specific
situations I I don't know what what are
your thoughts around that it is
something I would consider the thing
you've got to be really careful about is
you don't want to end up giving
Financial advice in a context where then
it blows up on you you know in some way
yeah um but I it would be at least
conceivably super interesting
yeah yeah thank you and then I have one
other quick question for you sure please
all right so um here you know in New
York we have um uh an oversight agency
of the police department called the
Civilian Complaint review board and um
they're considered to be one of the I
guess what you would say Premier
agencies in the country when it comes to
oversight of police misconduct
um and so but what I'm saying a lot is
uh folks uh criticizing them for being
ineffective and they're there's
legislation actually in the state that's
um trying to remove the agency and
replace it with something else and so my
question is not specifically about the
agency but it's about the idea and I
think I've heard you say this once
before about
um if we are going to we can criticize
for example Biden for policies and stuff
like that but um if we don't have
something to replace it with what or
what what are we to do you know and it's
like I it just frustrates me a lot of
the time that um people want to
criticize like certain you know
philosophies or certain things that are
existing not even a philosophy like
things are in place but how are you
going to replace what you're criticizing
and what is you know and how do you
suppose people can deal with that or or
as a movement of progressives even you
know well you're getting at something
that is um you know it's one of these
truisms where it's very it's much easier
to criticize than it is to come up with
solutions to problems and that doesn't
necessarily mean that just because
you've identified a problem but you
don't have a solution you should be
ignored I mean it's it's not that real
like let me give you an example this is
it's it's sort of um it's it's kind of
silly but it also makes sense you could
be watching a car race a NASCAR race
race and know nothing about NASCAR
vehicles but identify a car that has
something wrong with it it's it's like
wobbling down the track and it's slower
than all the others and there's blue
smoke coming out of it
even without knowing much about how to
fix that problem you could identify that
something is wrong so I don't want to
laugh off the fact
that it's totally legit to say hey you
know what
the status quo with student lending
isn't working you've got all these
people they take out these student loans
college is outrageously expensive they
graduate they have a crazy debt but the
job they get doesn't pay much money that
it's great that we can identify that you
don't necessarily need to know whether
the solution comes from regulation or a
higher minimum wage or making it harder
to borrow or putting price caps on
colleges or creating a job market that's
more uh robust for non-college stuff you
don't have to know the answer to be able
to identify a problem so I I don't think
that it's useful to just say hey just
pointing out problems doesn't really
have value however if you're in a
position of power as an elected official
or you're arguing that you should be
voted into a position of power you damn
well better have some suggestions as to
how to fix the problem
that makes absolute uh sense to me thank
you for that input uh yeah thank you I
appreciate that that makes a lot of
sense all right Nick from Harlem thanks
for the call
thank you all right there he goes now on
to all sorts of other things Nick from
Harlem let's go to Chris from Georgia
Chris from Georgia welcome to the
program
um I'll let you get settled here and
unmute yourself what's on your mind
today
Chris from Georgia you're on I can't
hear you though probably you have your
wrong audio device selected
Chris from Georgia welcome to the show
all right and there goes
Chris from Georgia that's sad I'm sad we
weren't able to make the connection
let's go to Tai from Iowa Ty from Iowa
welcome what's going on hello David can
you hear me yes I can
okay
um so I wanted to ask this I just
thought this was kind of weird so
I noticed you know how like a lot of
Republicans will say like well the
Democrats are just Communists and
socialists and all this stuff right yeah
so I think it's kind of weird like I
remember Trump put out that one thing
and he said like China would have never
flew a spy balloon over me because China
respects me too much yeah
I just thought that was really kind of
weird to hear well it's absurd I mean we
we have we since found out that China
did fly spy balloons during Trump's term
uh Trump apparently they did Trump
apparently wasn't told about it which
fine but the idea that they respect him
too much or fear him too much and this
actually gets to a broader issue of of
the idea of fear as the way to get power
and uh respect in politics you know fear
and this came up during my interview on
the Patrick Bet David podcast where he
said is it bad that nobody fears the us
anymore and I was like well what
evidence do you have of that he was like
forget it you know like we got off onto
a different thing but fear will make
your
adversaries and allies
involve you only enough to minimize the
threat from you but not enough to make
you a serious participant and so like
the fear example let's let's Grant maybe
other countries were afraid of trump
they were afraid because he was so
unstable and that only gets them to deal
with Trump in a way that will be the
minimum to prevent him from doing
something completely insane but he'll
never be taken seriously when fear is
the main thing that goes on and so
that's why I think that this idea of
fear to gain power is fundamentally
flawed
yeah it just was kind of weird to hear
because it's kind of like he
it seems like he'll praise China when
need be but then he'll also say that the
Democrats are communist but then it's
like well you're you're praising this
thing that to you is like a far left
dictatorship it doesn't really make a
lot of sense you know right absolutely
um yeah I think uh so so that's my view
on that I hope I've answered your
question
yeah that makes sense all right Ty from
Iowa thank you for the call
all right thank you all right there he
goes some pretty solid calls today I
must say let's go next to Moni from the
United Kingdom Moni welcome to the
program what's on your mind today
oh yeah I actually just got back from
work I love the show I just wanted to
say keep up the good work well welcome
thank you
um so I wanted to bring something up
that uh has been playing on my mind for
a bit now and I never really saw anyone
bring it up and it's when Barton did the
State of the Union Address fairly
recently yes
um no one seemed to point out that when
Biden brought up the
whole idea of funding the border patrol
officers actually getting the money and
equipment that they deserve and they
need
um on the CNBC news station it actually
cut to Ted Cruz and his reaction he was
sitting there shaking his head and
complaining and I just don't get why
oh uh it's I mean I don't know how
familiar you are with in general how
it's a complete partisan show but yeah
yeah it's mostly that I mean it's you
know that that's what people like Ted
Cruz have to do they have to complain
they have to shake their their head they
have to ask act disgusted even about
like uncontroversial things
yeah I mean it's just such a shame
because
um I mean clearly that's he always says
that the Border needs to get more
funding and more equipment and stuff
like that and and then as soon as it's
proposed he sits there and shakes his
head like that you know yeah like who he
is but it's a chance to see that it's
pathetic it's what it's what his voters
expect him to do and he's not a serious
person that's the reality
listen can I ask you a question I'm
curious if you have some insights I'm
soon going to be making my triumphant
return to the United Kingdom and I'm
going to have the opportunity to spend a
little bit of time on the south coast of
England you know where Brighton and
Bournemouth you know the area yes yeah
if I had the opportunity to choose any
place to spend a few days in that area
is there a particular spot you would
recommend like is Brighton better than
Bournemouth or what where would you go
I I haven't really been too uh
Bournemouth in my life I'm I'm kind of
almost between Brighton and London okay
that's where I live but I go down to
Worthing and Brighton quite often
Brighton's really nice
um it is what a lot of us like to call
the LGBT capital of Britain for the most
part or the south of Britain anyway oh
really well those spots usually have
some of the better food scenes is that
the case in Brighton as well Brighton
does have a lot of good food options oh
interesting yes and it's right on the
water correct
yeah it's right by the beachfront
depending on where you stay in Brighton
of course maybe Brighton is a place to
check out that's interesting yeah
Brighton's always the the go-to beach
area I think I'm not going to speak for
all people from the UK but you I would I
know you would never do that you would
never ever all right good I'm gonna look
into that I appreciate the advice but no
I I love um I've been looking a lot into
U.S politics recently and you've been
doing some good work out there so thank
you for all that I appreciate that thank
you so much yeah thank you have a good
day all right money from the UK folks
let's end it there because we couldn't
possibly end on a higher note we will
take calls again and I hope to hear from
you next time
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right let's get into the mailbag it
is Friday time to look at what some of
you wrote to me over the last week you
can email info davidpackman.com leave a
YouTube comment leave leave anything
quite frankly we might use it first one
we sometimes start with something
negative I know the first one today is
from Jordan who is doing the right thing
he's using the wrong your in hate mail
which is almost required at this point
you're a bozo y-o-u-r Jordan writes to
me do you really think you have
everything figured out Joe Biden has
been on hibernation since 2020 and this
country is a power keg not a powder keg
it's a power keg just once I'd want to
see you honest with your Audience by
putting on clown makeup and a skirt if
you love Biden so much you should go to
sleep every day well you know Jordan I
do go to sleep every day I think
sleeping is really important and it is
stunning to me how someone like this can
hold any job any job
some of these folks could be your kids
teachers they might be your accountant
now maybe Jordan doesn't have a job I
don't know but
um
let's move on
I was uh surprised but I guess not
really you know we launched the Spanish
YouTube channel last week quite
literally within minutes of the Spanish
YouTube channel launching I got my first
hate Spanish email where Alexander wrote
to me
which means
son of a communist
trash blood I have trashy blood folks uh
don't you say anything about my blood
until you see my CBC results and you'll
be stunned
um no listen in all seriousness
the Spanish content is triggering people
left and right and it's wild and I told
you there's a lot of right-wing
conspiracy theories targeted at the
Spanish-speaking community and that's
why we've taken on this Spanish language
dubbing project over a thousand of you
have already subscribed if you've got
friends family parents cousins whoever
who wants to be getting content like
what we create but they would rather get
it in Spanish than in English tell them
about
davidpackman.com
Spanish
Spanish Scott wrote in about my mustache
and says David sir so much commentary
from viewers who are activated and
triggered by any changes to the show set
background guest hosts your attire Etc
please Count Me In amongst those who are
eagerly tuning in to watch the progress
of the mustache looking better every day
my friend that's Scott in New York City
well thank you you know I was going to
start it only as a goof but I'm sort of
enjoying the mustache when people see me
who haven't seen me for you know a few
weeks or a couple of months I noticed
that they do a double take but they
don't want to bring it up and I'll
immediately say it's the mustache right
and they can't help but say yes it is
the mustache this is a satirical
mustache to be completely clear but it
is generating interest and Intrigue and
that is really more than I can ask for
so I'm going to keep it going uh the
Shaving has much improved it's all it's
it's just it's all going really really
well is what I would say Scott so we're
going to keep it going for the time
being okay a couple emails about my
interview with Patrick Bet David when I
was down in Florida a couple weeks ago
Craig Rhoden
about the pbd approach to debating Craig
says you talking about him was the first
I'd heard of him and he just turned me
off he would ask you a question that I'm
sure you would have a straightforward
answer to but then you would immediately
present an analogy that he feels would
trick you into answering how he would
like then when you ask him
straightforward questions he wouldn't
answer instead he would ask where are
you going with this thinking you are
trying to trick him into saying the
wrong thing and he doesn't want to get
beat at his own game also his come on
you're a smart person is very
condescending I'm curious your thoughts
thanks that's Craig from Maui yeah Craig
you're right about everything you're
saying I thought it was super
interesting perfectly nice guy you know
and we chatted very briefly before and
after the show and
um all of it and perfectly nice guy but
um I did think that it wasn't
necessarily bad faith it did seem in a
way that he was just so careful not to
fall into any kind of a trap like when I
said to him
when you think about the tax rate you're
willing to pay like are you willing to
pay more if you get more for your taxes
like if it included college and Health
Care would you be willing to pay more
than if it didn't it really wasn't a
trick question it was trying to open a
conversation about what we value and he
was saying something like well I don't
think we're spending it the right way
and I'm like that's not the question I'm
asking sir
um Craig's assessment is pretty pretty
spot on
uh and and maybe I will have another
opportunity to try again Renee also
wrote in about the interview with
Patrick Bett David and said hi David I'm
listening to your chat with Patrick Bett
David I've never heard of this guy but
his arguments remind me so much of
trying to have a conversation with my
stepdad who's good-hearted but so
exasperating I'm not sure if I can make
it through this whole thing because when
you try to pinpoint one issue he throws
10 other random examples and says well
what about this what about that like
lending a bike to someone is the same as
centralizing how we fund health care
it's so hard to get anywhere with people
who have this world view but thank you
for trying yeah this was a very common
um sort of email I got feedback wise I
think the most interesting outcome of
the Patrick Bet David interview is that
usually the home team has a huge bias to
the host so for example I would expect
that when I upload my interviews with
pbd
um the comments would be mostly positive
about me and they were and I would
expect that on his channel the video we
did would be mostly positive about him
interestingly tons of his viewers on his
channel said in the comments you were
unnecessarily hostile this didn't go
well for you Pat etc etc the fact that
that was even
a noticeable portion of the feedback
from his audience is very interesting I
don't know what it means but it's
certainly very very interesting and I
would be interested in doing it again
nolita wrote In and says are you able to
post a link on the main webpage for the
Spanish broadcast I can't find it David
said it quickly I didn't catch it I'm
going to say the link again with total
peace and love
davidpackman.com
Spanish as of this moment we have
breached 1500 subscribers on the channel
and we got our first video with over a
thousand views on the Spanish Channel it
is extraordinarily exciting
extraordinarily exciting and we're going
to be putting in a bunch of different
resources into the project because I
think it is so important Ron wrote in
about the Ohio train derailment and Ron
said something I've been seeing
everywhere I've been seeing it on
Twitter I've been seeing it on Reddit
Ron says David can you provide coverage
of the Ohio train derailment I feel like
this is a major story that should be
getting more coverage but isn't getting
the attention it deserves I genuinely
don't understand why I am seeing this
comment everywhere there's a narrative
that's developed that nobody's talking
about the train derailment I see it
everywhere I I go to newyorktimes.com
it's about the train derailment I go to
Washington Post train derailment Fox
News train derailment because they want
to criticize Pete boot Edge and Joe
Biden about it Reddit all over the train
derailment Twitter all over the trend
derailment independent you know media
we've already done a number of clips
about it and so have many of our
colleagues I am not seeing
that there isn't coverage of this and I
don't know what people you know it's
happened in other cases where there's a
story that's like everywhere and you see
people saying this it's not getting any
coverage and yet everybody is talking
about it I don't really know where
that's coming from I'd be interested to
know more and if you have any sense of
why that narrative is being repeated let
me know because I am seeing coverage
about every aspect of this what caused
it the controlled burn Mike dewine the
chemicals is the water safe is the air
safe is the soil safe is this Pete
Buddha judge's fault or not is this Joe
Biden's fault or not the Obama
regulations that Donald Trump wrote I'm
seeing every aspect of the story covered
extensively and it is an important story
so we should be seeing that but I'm just
not seeing the lack of coverage let me
know if you know where that's coming
from we have such a great bonus show for
you to
you can sign up so quickly
at joinpakman.com
if you want to pay the normal prices
that's great I believe that they're
eminently reasonable six bucks a month
60 for the year if that strikes you as
high for your financial situation no
problem I have a coupon code for you
that code is 24 starts now the number
2424 starts now no spaces okay 2024
really does start right now we're in the
middle of it already sign up you'll get
the bonus show the commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show invitations
to our members only town halls and
access to the sound board Obama yeah we
have a soundboard in the members section
of the website
for our members check it out we will see
you on the bonus show momentarily